what's going on members of the Rob core
you read that title correctly we are
back with death of Venom verse and null
returns in this story The symbiot God so
to answer a question some of you guys
had yes this is the main Marvel Universe
version of the carned symbiot no it does
not take place in the main Marvel
Universe the Carnage symbiot is out in
the Multiverse killing every version of
Venom it can possibly find right so just
kind of clear that up a little bit so
what this does is this opens up at the
tail end of the last video that we
covered and as always if you need to get
caught up at the end of this video we'll
have a playlist for you guys to click on
so you can get caught up with death of
venomverse but basically the forces that
are out there right the anti- Carnage
forces basically brought in antivenom
and historically speaking antivenom has
been a symbiot that can actually kill
off and eradicate other symbiotes a
perfect example of this was when it
almost took away the radioactive
material in Peter Parker's blood and it
basically would have turned him into a
regular guy and he wouldn't have been
Spider-Man anymore The Hope in doing
this is that it would have effectively
neutralized the Carnage symbient like
pouring an exceedingly strong acid on a
relatively weak material it would have
just dissolved it such as it is what it
ended up doing is it actually allowed
all the different versions of Venom that
Carnage has ever killed and consumed to
basically Escape it allowed them to kind
of rise up against him the difference
here is that instead of coming back as
their normal form the antivenom
properties mer Ed with them basically
turning them into anti- Carnage
symbiotes which is amazing and I'm kind
of amazed that we never really had
anything like that before right like
anti-c carnate symbat just so you guys
who are new to Comics just so you know
this is how new Concepts pop up because
what's going to happen mark my words at
some future point in time another writer
is going to draw on this in the main
Marvel Universe with regards to Carnage
and you're going to start seeing an
anti- Carnage symbiot that exists out
there right toxin You could argue that
to a degree but not really right I mean
he's kind of a merger of both but a true
anti- carnate symbiot that will appear
in the future but this goes exactly the
way that you would expect it to that
with these anti-c carnate symbiotes
they're largely at least seem to be
immune to the forces or at least to the
abilities of the carnate symbiot itself
there really doesn't seem to be a whole
lot he can do to basically reabsorb them
conquer them so on and so forth we're
actually going to see that's not the
case Cas here in a little while but the
cool thing is that now they see it as
their opportunity now they see it as
their chance to basically take Carnage
down once and for all now one of the
things that we get to see here which is
really really cool is a dreamstone Venom
now for those you guys who don't know
what that means in Marvel Comics in the
war of Realms crossover event which was
effectively like a massive Asgardian
conflict that ultimately came to Earth
there was a point where a dreamstone was
presented to Eddie Brock and the idea
behind the dreamstone is that it can
grant the various desires of whoever it
is that wields it in the case of Eddie
Brock it was a Venom symbiot that could
manifest all kinds of weapons that were
outside the traditional scope of what a
Venom symbiot was capable of it was an
artificial way to enhance his abilities
and it lasted for a relatively short
period of time and then we went into the
current Venom run where he became the
king in Black after defeating null and
all that kind of crazy stuff which was
cool but the thing about this is that
this version of Venom can basically
craft all kinds of physical arms and
Armament which is how it is that he's
able to take the symbiot and almost kind
of convert his physical structure into
that of almost like a a Godlike type
Warrior being with like a massive Scythe
right the Venom symbiot can't normally
do that but in effect it allows him to
do what a Carnage symbiot can do which
is pretty awesome and it's pretty cool
to see now everybody else just kind of
takes their shots where they can when
they can and Truth to tell they get a
little carried away with themselves
right they get a little carried away
with like dragging the conflict on
everybody trying to get their own licks
in as opposed to just trying to take him
out as fast as humanly possible and
that's why you see like Anne weing who's
kind of the leader of this anti- Carnage
Force it's just kind of like you know
don't give him a chance to get his
footing he's weakened but he's still
dangerous that kind of a thing the
reality is if they were doing what they
were supposed to do they would have
annihilated him right off the bat
because one of the things that an
realize when these different consumed
Venoms had escaped from Carnage is that
he was now back to his normal weakness
right the same weaknesses that all
symbiotes have fire Sonics electricity
that kind of thing so it would be
relatively easy to destroy this guy but
they let it drag on a little bit too
long and that's exactly how this plays
out right that you basically have
dreamstone venom who goes in for the
killing blow and then he ends up being
impaled by Carnage right and Carnage
like kills him on the spot so what this
does is it basically turn faces
everything that we've seen so far that
were Carnage him self even believed that
these guys were Beyond his ability to
absorb that with the death of dreamstone
Venom this shows that Carnage can start
killing all of them right he could start
going after all of them just like he
hoped he could and that's when he kind
of goes back on the offense again that's
kind of the cool thing right the Carnage
literally had a kind of crisis of
confidence in the moment when he lost
the people that he had absorbed because
he thought he was back to being his
normally weak self it's awesome to see
that's not the case now the dream
symbiot actually bonds itself to a
different version of Eddie Brock who got
the Venom symbiot and became Spider-Man
and in turn you almost have a kind of
double symbiot bonded to a person right
Venom times 2 and when this guy
manifests right he says Like You Had
Your Shot Carnage you got close but you
blew it and we think you know that we
are Venom right so literally this is not
Eddie Brock from the main Marvel
Universe this what I want to establish
here that version of Eddie Brock is off
doing the whole King in Black fighting
Meridius right achieving Godlike levels
of power that's not what's going on here
this is just an alternate version of
Eddie that just happens to have two
symbiotes bonded to him now instead of
one but this is a really cool moment
here because what it does is it shows
how powerful Carnage is now this is a
massive boost because one thing to know
Carnage has not reabsorbed any other
symbiotes so this is just the Carnet
symbiot by itself over the years in
Marvel Comics ever since the original
introduction of Carnage going into like
the the original Maximum Carnage event
we always knew there seemed to be this
kind of power discrepancy between the
Venom symbiot the Carnage symbiot and
Spider-Man there was just something
about him that seemed to make him more
powerful and Marvel's hinted at it over
the years right it's stronger and faster
than Venom that kind of thing but what
really seemed to set Carnage over the
top was the fact that there were no real
mental blocks in place there was no
morality Clause here right right Venom
over the years has kind of waxed and
waned and changed and things like that
and even when Venom and and Spider-Man
first teamed up when Carnage first
appeared it was like okay look we got to
put our animosity towards each other to
the side and we have to like face off
against this this joint enemy right the
enemy of my enemy is my friend with
Carnage it's not that way right either
he's going to kill you or he's not and
there really is no in between so that
just kind of recklessness and that lack
of concern for anybody's life or the
value of life in any capacity seemed to
kind of put him over the
what this establishes here is assuming
all things are equal which is to say the
the capabilities and the strength of one
Venom symbiot in a universe is
comparable if not exact to another Venom
symbiot in Another Universe assuming
that's all the same Carnage is Way
Beyond the normal abilities of Venom in
any one particular Universe right which
really kind of shows how it was he was
able to so easily overcome these
different Venoms that existed in these
different alternate realities because
that was the question a lot of you guys
had a lot of you guys were kind of like
how is how is Carnage able to just so
easily kill Venoms they should be able
to put up a pretty considerable fight
and it shouldn't be like a cat- and
mouse game this kind of establishes why
that's the case but even then with his
back against the wall to a degree he
starts reaching out and grabbing each
and every one of these different
symbiotes that he had previously
absorbed and reabsorbs them back into
himself that takes his power back to
where it was before but now he's even
more powerful than was before and the
reason for that is because the first
thing he does is he takes out antivenom
right kills this guy right on the spot
so now he doesn't have to worry about
them using their abilities to like force
these different Venom symbiotes out of
his body or anything along those lines
and the other forces right the Venom
forces start to realize this window's
closing incredibly fast but honestly
it's closing faster than they think it
is because there really is no
conceivable way for these guys to defeat
him now right there's just not going to
happen so all the that ends up happening
here is he goes after the Venom symbiot
that has the dreamstone takes this guy
out and absorbs it and then in turn he
goes forward once everybody just kind of
teleports away because the best they can
do is just Flee for their lives Remar
their forces and try to come back and
take another shot at him at some point
in time this transitions over to another
universe and what you have here is a
Silver Surfer who became Venom the
kicker to all of this and what's so cool
about this is that this guy is about to
be met with the power of the Enigma
Force and that's where things go
sideways really for pretty much
everybody in the Multiverse the reason
for that and for those of you guys who
don't know in Marvel Comics you have
What's called the microverse in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it's called
the quantum realm but the microverse is
literally a microscopic Universe from
that microscopic Universe comes the
Enigma Force Marvel calls it the Enigma
Force because they just never bothered
to explain what it was that it could
really do it's the power of light and
like that's it right it's just it's
literally a plot device right like it
does whatever the user needs it to do in
order to like win right Spider-Man
punches The Incredible Hulk into the
atmosphere during acts of Vengeance for
example so the thing about this is that
by absorbing right killing this Silver
Surfer symbiot and absorbing the Enigma
Force into itself Carnage now becomes
the total antithesis of null the symbiot
God why because that was established in
the king and black storyline if you guys
remember that and this is a great call
back if you guys remember that story
that the Enigma Force was kind of like
the light to the darkness that null
represented when Eddie Brock attained
the Enigma Force in the original King
and black event that's how it was he was
able to defeat null that's exactly what
happens with Carnage here but the
question has to be asked what happens
when a bad guy gets this well you
transition to a full contingent of the
Avengers the X-Men like even Clea who's
Doctor Strange in this universe all of
whom are channeling their powers
together to try to defeat null the
symbiot god in this universe none of it
works but what ends up happening here is
Carnage now with the power of the Enigma
Force and the hellmark which basically
allows him to tap into the abilities of
Mesto summoning demons and so on
immediately makes a beline for this
universe's version of null the symbiot
God and the fight is amazing because the
aveng of this universe have no clue
what's going on now this is one of the
things that I do want to establish here
because they look up in the sky and
they're like is that Carnage right
taking the fight to null and it's like I
mean it looks like it what's the call
here right and Magneto just kind of
looks for a second and it's like the
enemy of my enemy as my friend right so
they basically form a kind of alliance
with Carnage now when I say they form an
alliance I mean they decide to fight
alongside Carnage we'll see what
Carnage's reaction to that Alliance is
here in a second but the fight between
him and null is intense now when it
comes to null the symbiot God one of the
things that we didn't know is how null
functioned right is null multiversal is
null Universal as a concept null is
multiversal but every Universe has its
own version of null that's what this
establishes so this fight between these
guys is just crazy because initially
null doesn't know how to respond to this
right like the whole statement here is
you are not from this realm a cast off
from another reality come here to face
Oblivion and the response of Carnage is
yes Oblivion is what I deserve if I
cannot destroy you null then what chance
do I have against the king in black and
the response of null is do you not know
me I am the king in Black now what null
doesn't realize is that in the main
Marvel Universe his reality's
counterpart right like that version of
himself in that Universe was destroyed
by Eddie Brock and Eddie became the new
King in Black of that Universe he didn't
know that he has no idea what's going on
in other realities all he knows is
what's going on in his universe and so
that's why Carnage says not on my world
not on the world that matters now of
course this is also hinting and really
establishing what we've already known
which is Carnage is doing all of this in
the first place because he's aware of
how powerful Eddie Brock is now he's
aware that Eddie Brock in the main Mar
universe is the king in Black his level
of power is Way Beyond that of carnage
and the only way for Carnage to finally
kill Eddie Brock as the king in black
and take his place as the king in black
is to harness enough power to be able to
topple him right to basically gain the
power of null the symbiot god combined
with all these other things that we've
seen the hellmark and so on and so forth
and that's what's so wild because at
that point basically The Avengers jump
in right Thor's like strike my friends
while we can right this is the moment in
which we turn the tide and Magneto even
uses his power over magnetism to seize
control of null cyclops's optic beams
are basically Modified by Doctor Strange
so instead of just pulling energy from
some other dimension because cyclops's
eyes are a portal to a different
dimension that he actually ends up
pulling energy from the dark dimension
which basically amplifies and makes his
powers even more capable than they have
been which is something that I really
want to see in the future right but none
of it works against null because at that
point Captain America turns to Carnage
and he's like on your feet Soldier
thanks to you we've got null on the
defensive we need you we can take him
down Avengers Assemble but before he can
say assemble Carnage kills
him Carnage kills Captain America right
and then null's like these are all
distractions so in fact when they
thought it was a team up between the
Avengers and Carnage it's actually a
team up between Carnage and null who
killed The Avengers together it's
amazing I absolutely love it because in
response we get like the most null
statement ever right where he's like I
have come to destroy this world to
murder it and no one will stand in my
way no one right and then we find out
that much like the original King in
Black event this version of null has
seiz control of the celestials in this
universe and the funny thing here is
Carnage doesn't care right he literally
says if it makes you feel better I'll
finish what you started I'll end this
world for you after your dead and when
one of the celestials tries to go after
him he kills it on the spot so literally
the power of Carnage is just at this
astronomical level now right a god that
is what I've become that is what I
always was now the forces of Anne weing
do show up here where they teleport in
like at this moment when Carnage is just
fighting null half a second too late
because had they shown up when like The
Avengers were alive they probably could
have mounted an effective resistance
against both Carnage and null such as it
is these guys are idiots so they always
show up late so the thing here is that
when they arrive they're kind of like
okay what do we do like how do we find a
way to defeat Carnage and they're like
well I mean we have to find a way to
keep ourselves alive and for a while
they basically fight dragons right these
guys are useless as tits and a Bor hog
they don't really serve a purpose at all
right so like literally Carnage fighting
null which is like the real main brunt
of all of this this it's it's one of the
best fights I've ever seen because null
in turn when like the forces of an try
to like hold him and capture him right
keep him in place that kind of thing
because the idea is to grab null and
basically teleport him away it's a smart
idea but a dumb idea at the same time
it's a smart idea in the moment because
they basically would prevent Carnage
from attaining the power of a king in
black and then everything would just
come crumbling down around them right
then he would be guaranteed to be
unstoppable so if they teleport null
potentially to some other reality that's
basically empty right like just a dead
world where like there's no heroes or
anything then like sure right then I
guess the Multiverse would be saved for
the time being but it's also kind of a
dumb decision because all Carnage has to
do is just jump to a different Universe
where null hasn't been destroyed kill
that version of null and then we're
right back to square run again right so
it's only ever really a stop Gap measure
such as it is it doesn't work because
again the forces of an suck and like no
the symbiot god escapes and then just
starts killing them all but only like
this is this is this is is so amazing
because in their attempts to capture
null they leave Carnage wide open this
guy stabs null through the chest right
and he's like oh I'll know your power
I'll know it all and I'll put it to much
better use than you ever would and
that's when they realize it's game over
done right because this guy immediately
absorbs n's power and I got to say man
Carnage as a king in Black like just
look at him man it looks J like it looks
so amazing but like this guy is now
Unstoppable there's no conceivable way
they can win and even an's son Dylan
right who like has this kind of powered
suit of armor and that's how they
teleport around where Ann's like we have
to get out of here his response is no no
no no no it's like you said before we
just need more forces right we just need
more guys so they open up a portal bring
in more guys it's LS to the slaughter
right I mean it's a killbox right
literally it's just Carnage ripping
through them all and there's nothing
they can do and Ann's like we have to
get out of here like stop teleporting
people in and Dylan's like no it's just
like you said right it's just like you
plan and she's she's like no we have to
leave there's no surviving this there's
no way we get out of this alive but
that's when Carnage starts to Target
Dylan because it's like if I can destroy
the guy who can teleport forces in but
can also teleport forces out then it's
game over for everybody here he kills
Dylan on the spot right just bow impales
this guy there's no way in or out and so
at that point when they try to seize him
he's just like nope done and just like
kills everybody here except for an
everybody's dead right like an Wang is
the only person left alive we don't
really even know why he spared her and
there's even this kind of Illusion to
the idea that maybe Dylan is not fully
dead right maybe Dylan may come back in
some capacity because lest we forget
right this version of Dylan the daughter
of Anne from their Universe this guy is
the one that basically became the king
and lack of his own Universe right like
he's the one that killed off all the
superheroes in that universe and
replaced them all with symbiots so it's
entirely possible that this kid may come
back but as it stands now man it's game
over sun sun sun dunzo so the question
has to be asked what happens when this
version of Carnage confronts the main
Marvel Universe Eddie Brock with all the
power that he has well we'll find out
whenever that story kicks off with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end if you need to get caught
up on death of Venom verse make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later peace